welcome back to New Rockstars it's me
Tommy B and we are just weeks away from
Mandalorian season three say that five
times fast for the second week in a row
the football gods have blessed us with
nerdy content during a Monday night
football game we also got to watch Tom
Brady get waxed on live TV which is just
so enjoyable for me thank you football
Gods thank you for Josh Allen this time
it was a brand new trailer for Mando
season three that not only gave us a
release date March 1st but also gave us
some incredible new scenes for all of
that head over to Eric's full breakdown
of the trailer on the channel right now
of course you know me I want to talk
about droids mandalorians grief cargo
tribute to ig-11 that statue he's
standing on the stormtrooper's head Feed
me more Daddy but you know there's one
scene I gotta talk about with you right
here right now that's right it's the
flashback to the night of Order 66 when
we see those Sabers ignite you all know
I'm a SIM for swords laser swords to be
specific so when I saw the trailer
featuring four Jedi Sabers drawn
approaching a door being sliced open by
another laser I didn't want any Wookie
leaking Wookie freak would do I made a
video about it so we've got four Jedi on
one side but I must know who the Fett's
on the other side of that door in order
to make my life more simple as I always
try to do I've narrowed it down to two
scenarios scenario one someone on the
other side is coming to kill those Jedis
scenario two someone on the other side
is coming through to help rescue them
and of course grogu I always take the
bad news first so let's start with who
it could be slicing down that door to
make a Jedi Kebab first things first
clone troopers this is the least sexy
option and I certainly hope it's not
just clone troopers carrying out Order
66 but it certainly stands to reason
that if just beyond the framing of those
four Jedi is a little baby grogu asleep
it is floating bassinet then the clone
troopers would be coming to kill them
okay Second Battle Droids I may have
lied here there is one less sexy option
than clone troopers now I want as badly
as all of you out there to believe that
that is a badass lightsaber slicing
through the door but let's be honest it
could just be one of those goofy yet
deadly battles droids using a laser
cutter let's get to some sexier options
random bounty hunters so it would make
sense once Order 66 was initiated the
Palpatine would utilize the seemingly
endless supply of bounty hunters to help
him Purge the Jedi could we see a black
chrysanthen Cameo maybe a cad Bane Cameo
what about that werewolf guy from The
Cantina scene in the New Hope in easier
earlier times maybe when he wasn't
drinking so much so there's no shortage
of killers and kidnappers for hire in a
galaxy far far away so it's not
impossible that some of them might have
gone to the Jedi Temple on the night of
the Jedi Purge if you haven't figured
out that I'm a nerd by this point in the
video then I don't know what to tell you
I like to think I wear my nerd cred on
my sleeve and sometimes I carry my nerd
cred in my hands and I make cool sounds
with it when I do
jealous
An Elegant weapon this is the night
Reaper from owner saber an absolutely
badass lightsaber that looks feels and
sounds so realistic you feel like you
could bust it open and pluck the kyber
crystal right out of there
don't do that at home kids I'm just
saying this thing rules you can
customize it to be any kind of Jedi Sith
or weird midpoint between the two maybe
a gray Jedi like we heard in the old
books the night Reaper has an SN pixel
soundboard with 16 sets of sound fonts
whether or not you want to sound like
Luke Obi-Wan Anakin or even Vader you
can also choose from nine blade colors
nine sets of Blade effects and nine
different blade ignition sounds but come
on baby
I think we all know that's the best one
it's also got smooth swing technology
when you're swinging around
it sounds as realistic as if you were
battling back Blaster bolts on the Death
Star say that three times fast if you've
got two Sabers you can take advantage of
the dueling features like flash on Clash
Blaster block lock up Loop and so much
more check out Ona saber on Instagram
and Tick Tock if you want to enter their
monthly giveaways or go to onasaber.com
and use code rockstars to save 20 at
checkout to get a saber of your own
blasters those are for brutes give me
this elegant ancient weapon any day all
right here's a wild card one Chief
Palpatine himself what better way to
celebrate your big day than it cap it
off with a little night slicing this is
uh probably a little far-fetched palpe
usually has other people doing his
bidding as he operates from the Shadows
meaning holy [__] Anakin Skywalker AKA
Darth Vader are we gonna get a cameo
from the newly minted Darth Vader in
Mando season three in a flashback scene
why not hating Christensen has forgiven
our snacky remarks and blessed us with a
pretty incred edible lightsaber battle
in Kenobi wouldn't it be nice to have
him kill some younglings again was that
too far wouldn't you like to watch a
fully limbed Vader Going Bonkers on some
Jedis we know his boss sheve covets
grogu so is Annie actually going ham on
pelpy's orders to find baby Yoda I don't
know I actually think this has a decent
chance of happening but I also think
that I'm gonna get super powers one day
so you shouldn't put too much stock into
anything anything that I say those are
exciting options but to me the most
exciting option would be if the door was
being lasered open by someone who hated
both Jedi and Sith someone who would
love to piss off Palpatine and steal his
little Jedi in a floating egg someone
like
Darth Maul or I guess he's just mall now
if you're nasty after the Clone Wars
Maul added the dark saber to his
collection he was briefly the leader of
the death watches what was the crime
family the shadow Collective he even
wielded both the darksaber and his
signature red saber against his former
Master Darth Sidious why not have Maul
be grogu's unlikely rescuer maybe it's
not a traditional lightsaber going down
that door May maybe it's the dark saber
it wouldn't be for any heroic reason
other than his own benefit but could you
imagine if this season had some yondu
quill like flashbacks with Maul and
grogu am I the only one starting to
breathe heavy am I okay I'm good okay
those are the bad and ugly choices but
what about the good guys and girls
slicing on the door to come to the
rescue first things first on the good
guy size Quinlan Voss Eric's great great
great great great great great great
great great great great grandfather he's
everyone's favorite non-celible Jedi and
he's confirmed alive in the live-action
Kenobi series but we have yet to gaze
upon him with our own faces on a Disney
plus screen Quinlan spent his post
Republic years rescuing and smuggling
Force sensitive children to safety on
the path so it quite literally is his Mo
what a debut it would be if Quinlan
rescued grogu and traveled the path to
some place the young Link could be
secure but if it's not him could it be
Mace Windu Mace Windu Mace Windu most
definitely not confirmed alive but a big
fan Theory favorite well Samuel L ignite
the purple saber for us one more time
time okay phrasing on that one there's
no way to say it without seeming like
I'm talking about it is there Sam
himself has said Jedis can fall from
incredible Heights and still survive and
he's game to return his Mace Windu so
what's stopping us help us Dave filoni
you're our only hope I know this seems
absurd but look at the recent Death
misdirection Star Wars has given us Maul
alive Ahsoka alive Palpatine somehow
alive hell even Max Rebo drank his meaty
blue thighs off that pleasure barge and
back into our hearts and book of Boba
Fett so I ask you why not when do we
also have cane and jars though he was
just an apprentice at the time after
being saved by the bad bash it's
possible that Kanan could have rescued
grogu and as many younglings as he could
before Hiding Out Of The Ghost and
living out the events of Star Wars
Rebels now I want to stop right here and
tell you I put this list together I
researched as many possible living Jedis
as I could for this thing I don't know
exactly where they all were it's really
hard to piece things together through
all of the extended Universe what's
Canon what's not so if you've got loaded
in your fingertips a comment ready to go
to prove me wrong these are just
hypotheticals maybe they want even there
maybe it wasn't possible but just for
once in your hearts if you've got a
nasty comment Take It Outside and shout
it into the sky and maybe it'll be heard
by your Costa new could Our Savior come
in the form of a heroic librarian hello
jacosta was in charge of the library at
the Jedi Temple in Coruscant and fled
before she could fall victim to The
Purge did she bring grogu with her and
she was trying to start a new Jedi
Training Center I mean he'd be a hell of
a first pupil let's get to some even
more long shots and a little bit of a
lightning round speaking of lightning
luminara unduly briefly managed to
escape before the grand Inquisitor
tracked her down and used a corpse to
lure Canada if I had a dime for every
time I used a corpse to lure someone in
one of the darker plot lines in the
galaxy far far away although we have
seen full planets explode and a woman
died during childbirth what about Seer
Gunda sir jundo was a Jedi Knight during
Order 66 and with her Apprentice Trilla
suduri she helped younglings Escape From
The Empire could one of these younglings
be grogu well she was hiding gender gave
herself up to stop the Empire from
discovering her Padawan and the
Younglings we know that eventually
gender broke down in the interrogation
and revealed the location of those young
is this how grogu's whereabouts was
discovered by moth Gideon I don't know
does it all connect the timing might be
a little off there but would be an
interesting way to tie the video games
and some novels into this TV show all
right now I've got the green Inquisitor
this is a stretch but I want more from
this guy if we only got him in 2.25
episodes of Kenobi and I get it he's not
a grand Inquisitor yet he's just a
disenchanted temple guard but still what
if he just went in there and took a
little grogu for himself because he's a
stinker huh finally my choice your
choice the choice that leads us all to
the right choice and the right choice
being the bar benevolent droids perhaps
the Droid bar we saw in the trailer will
be shown in a flashback as a ragtag
group of friendly droids celebrating the
rescuing of grogu now wouldn't that be
happy would you like your oil shaken or
filtered okay that was a bad joke that
was a joke for all you spark plug
Fanatics all you oil change freaks all
your Lube heads out there we gotta get
out of here but I want to give a quick
plug before we go I'll be appearing at
kybercon in Fairfield California on
February 11th I'll have a link in all of
my social media bios and how you can get
tickets to come see me and a bunch of
other great guests we'll talk we'll
shake hands we'll talk Star Wars we'll
talk Marvel we'll talk to Buffalo Bills
let's go Josh Allen please don't break
my heart I need to recharge my cover
Crystal so that's gonna do it for me
please follow me at Tommy bechtold
follow new rockstars on all platforms
don't forget to like this channel
subscribe to this channel for all the
nerdy news you need and do not forget to
subscribe to our new new channel the
Deep dive launching February 17th that's
all for now I have spoken
[Music]